alright by request we are making coffee
today I'm going to make three coffee
drinks we're going to make espresso
espresso macchiato and a popular one in
my home country of Argentina Cortado and
I will explain what all of them are what
do we need first I'll go over it okay so
we have two espresso cups we have two
plates we have two spoons we have a
towel which we are going to dampen we
have a two shot filter basket we have
cold milk and of course we have beans
beans very very important these are
artisanal beans that have been blessed
by a designee of the 14th Dalai Lama and
then they were beaten with bamboo in a
sort of ritualistic ceremony and those
are the beans we're going to be using
today beans very very important first
step we're going to put hot water in our
cups to warm them up keep them warm
next step is we are going to run some
water through the filter basket and the
filter just to get it up to temperature
and once the water drains out you do
want to make sure that these are dry
because if the coffee gets wet before
you want it to get wet it's not going to
be good for anybody so we've got that
hot to the touch and ready to go I will
pop it in and next we've got to grind
some of those artisanal beans and the
ground coffee takes up a lot more space
before you compress it so I like to
grind in stages we're almost there
Wow
smell the ground coffee Luis amazing and
then and we are basically ready to make
coffee alright we are almost ready to go
we'll take that hot water that has been
warming these cups and we will get rid
of that and put it into the drip tray I
will take our coffee ready to make two
shots of espresso here put it in as far
as it goes
I will take my cups put them underneath
and since we are making two shots here I
will press the two shot button
Wow Lois Wow
all right so we now have two shots of
espresso here we'll let it keep dripping
and move this out of the way take a look
at this you've got some great crema
there which I know is very very exciting
to a lot of people all right let me put
these down for now now normally if we
weren't trying to get this done I would
take this and as you will see I'm
emptying it here and then I would clean
this entire thing out I'm just going to
put this aside for now because time is
of the essence today all right so I said
we were making three drinks espresso was
the first one that's it this is espresso
it's just the coffee but we're going to
turn it into a different drink so I'll
put it aside for now next step is we do
need some milk this is the milk jug the
downside is we kind of need to heat more
milk up than we need for this little
project if you don't have enough milk in
the jug
it really will not foam properly so I'm
going to probably have to put in a
little more milk than what I really need
but that's okay because it's all for
science all right we're going to turn
the steam on got to give it about 10 or
15 seconds to really get going
all right so we will pause and then we
will go back on and you really want to
find the spot where you get just a
little bit of air in there and a camera
in your face will definitely affect your
ability to do this all right we want to
make sure that milk is hot enough for
what I don't know but it's got to be hot
enough all right
we'll take that out and we want to
immediately clean this because otherwise
it can get pretty bad
so we have milk here we have it's foamy
its milk it's fantastic so we had the
espresso step one to turn that into an
espresso macchiato is literally taking a
dollop of foam and putting it in and we
now have an espresso macchiato drink
number two on a plate with a comically
small spoon and now we will take our
second drink we were making a Cortado
which literally means cut cut with milk
and we will take a little bit of that
milk and put it in and then why not a
little bit of foam it looks similar but
it's not we have espresso macchiato and
Cortado
it's pretty good
yup all night
it's good